this is not going to be an easy show to
explain or describe but you know what
i wouldn't have it any other frilling
way
[Music]
hey there folks
i gotta gush a little bit about farscape
now this isn't really topical at least
not in the grand scheme of things it's
somewhat topical to me because this
month will mark the end of the podcast
project i've been doing for
almost two years now with jesse gender
called what the frel which is on the
council of geeks podcast feed there's a
link for that down in the description if
you never noticed it before
and that was where we watched every
episode of farscape and did a podcast
review and discussion of it for me it
was a rewatch because i fell in love
with the show in the early 2000s for
jessie it was her very first time
watching it having now finished it up
for me for the second time
i just need to gush
a bit about this show and maybe even
bring some attention to it for those who
have never heard of it
so farscape was the brainchild of one
rockness o'bannon who had done some work
on the revived version of the twilight
zone and also had been the mind behind
the alien nation film and then
subsequent tv series which is
okay
it's interesting it's not amazing
farscape was his idea and it is just set
in a galaxy far far away not a long long
time ago though so that's the legal
distinction legally distinct the best
kind of distinct no seriously though
it's not really any resemblance to star
wars it is very much its own thing and
one has to wonder if part of the initial
reason for it being created was just to
give the henson creature shop something
to make other than fantasy stuff and
muppets it features
all kinds of bizarre aliens from
elaborate makeups to insane puppetry you
can forget about the standard star trek
model of put a couple bumps on the
forehead and like maybe a ridge in the
nose that's an alien oh no oh no no no
that will not do for far escape but i'm
getting ahead of myself
let's talk premise premise is actually
pretty basic it deals with a an
astronaut by the name of john crichton
played by ben browder and he while
running an experiment in his module in
earth orbit
ends up getting caught in a wormhole and
shot
across the galaxy to a place
that he does not know
and does not know him the first thing
that he encounters is a ship called moya
which is a living
ship
get used to sentences like that
they happen
a lot
now it's not like it's a giant being
that they that the crew travels inside
of its guts it's a biomechanical ship
but moya is alive
and has her own thoughts and instincts
and agenda every now and then
and he gets pulled on board moya
gets injected with some translator
microbes so we can actually understand
what's being said to him and encounters
folks like
dargo this massive hulking brute with
tendrils on his face who seems very
angry all the time and a woman who is
all blue and a tiny little frog looking
guy and that's before he even gets to
meet the ship's pilot who is literally
physically integrated into the ship
though also a separate entity from moya
but is the cruise means of communicating
with moya because they can't communicate
with her directly they have to do it
through pilot who also has his own
thoughts and his own needs and his own
agenda added to the mix aaron sun
played by claudia black and i'm not
going to say that aaron is my favorite
character of firescape
i am going to say though that i think
claudia black might be the mvp
of the show
she
packs
so much into this character right from
the beginning and to watch the journey
that she goes on over the course of this
show
it's gold
the work she puts in is amazing that's
not to undersell anybody else all the
acting's great but aaron is a sebatian
who looks human but is not they're
actually a bit more reptilian she's
literally cold-blooded
but she is a member of the peacekeepers
local peacekeeping force that is
let's go with a little bit um
iron fisted
and uh she after
angering her superior officer captain
krase also finds herself now stuck on
moya so we have a ship
with its own thoughts and its own mind
piloted by a being with its own thoughts
and its own mind that can suggest and
make recommendations of the ship but
does that actually strictly speaking
directly control the entire thing
and then we have a crew made up of
people who are all on the run this is a
crew of escaped prisoners plus
one space boy
hi there's your starting setup
they don't know
where they're going
they just know nobody wants them
and they are stuck in an area called the
uncharted territories now there's
certainly stuff there there's
civilizations there's trading routes
whatever but it's just
not a well-known region of space and
it's where they have to be to avoid
being picked up by the peacekeepers and
that's just your starting premise
there's additional characters who get
added to the show over time or who gain
additional depth there's tiana who just
her movement her very way of getting
around is weird and off-putting and
alien there's jewel who i didn't love uh
initially but she did grow on me sakozu
a little bit more mysterious even
naranti who bugged the heck out of me
when she first got introduced by the
time the show was done
now i kind of liked her
there's stark who's a little bit of an
intermittent character he shows up from
time to time
they could overdo his manic tendencies
but for the most part he was a pretty
compelling character but then
villains
let's talk villains
so there is chris who is our starter
villain who has a vendetta against jon
because when john first showed up in
this sector of space
a uh fighter from the peacekeepers
clipped his module and then crashed
exploded and that was piloted by chris's
brother and grace
has a serious grudge
and chris just starts out as a guy out
for revenge
and he gains a lot of depth as time goes
on has a really interesting arc
but then there's the real villain of the
show who gets introduced towards the end
of the first season
my friends
scorpius
such a great villain
his look his manner he is intimidating
he is in control he is patient
but he is also not above
moments of anger
if he thinks he's going to eventually
get what he wants he can be
very
very patient
frighteningly so
but if things start to go off in a
direction he does not feel he can
control he can get angry and that's its
own kind of scary i cannot risk killing
the knowledge that he possesses
and he knows that
and he is
methodical
and pragmatic but also invested
he can be cold and calculating but he
has personal investment in what's going
on he is
kind of everything and a character who
is like everything especially as a
villain should not work but
wow does he ever
he is so
so good as the primary villain of the
overall show
the aliens the creatures the settings
the stories
all have a little twist with them
one of the things that i really treasure
about firescape is the fact that it will
on more than a few occasions do what is
ultimately a pretty stock
space adventure episode you know the
kind of baseline premise that you
probably would have seen in something
like any number of star trek shows or
lost in space or the expanse or stargate
or
what have you
but
they tend to put
a little twist on it
a little something
to just shake it up i'll give an example
from an episode that i actually don't
even think is very good but is very
illustrative of what i'm talking about
in the episode jeremiah crichton
creighton finds himself briefly stranded
on a planet and when the other members
of the crew eventually come down to get
him the locals
begin to praise rigel
who is the little frog looking dude
as
a god
now the
visitor from space being viewed as a god
is a
stock story and generally the way that
works is that it becomes a story about
the misapplication of faith or the
misunderstanding of a more
quote-unquote primitive society and it
does that kind of thing it can often
come across as a bit
well a bit patronizing
and it's usually not very good and here
it's not great but they do a little
twist on it
which is
he kind of
is their god or rather the hinerians
which is his race and the dominars which
he is he's a deposed leader
did send out a whole bunch of like
starting
basically starter kit colonies
there is a statue of a hinerian there
and his family lineage would have sent
them out and then over time
because hinerians are very long lived
and the high near empire has been around
for a very long time but just through
the sheer passage of time and being cut
off from direct communication with the
rest of the empire
the mandate of we are doing this for our
dominar because we are doing this to our
for our god becomes a religious doctrine
and now
their god walks among them
again
not a massive departure
but they won't just do the tropes
straight they'll do the tropes they'll
have fun with the tropes
but they're not just gonna do them
without a little
bit of far scape flavor in them
but
i think
if i were to really get into things it's
gonna start getting something a bit more
spoilery and honestly if you haven't
seen the show when you like
sci-fi adventure
and you like things a little weird
i do recommend this show quite a bit
here's what i'm going to do before i go
any further
i'm going to recommend
a test episode i'm going to recommend to
you an episode that i think is a good
metric for viewers who have not seen
fireskate before to take a look at and
if this is your jam
start the show from the beginning so the
episode i'm going to recommend is from
season two it's episode four it's called
crackers don't matter
and i'm not going to tell you too much
about what's going on with it i think
you can just watch and it speaks for
itself but that will give you a taste of
the kinds of weirdness that you're in
for
and you can decide if that is your jam
and it's also pretty standalone and it's
the kind of base very self-contained
plot that like as long as you know the
basic setup of
there's a human in space with a ton of
aliens that's really all you need to
know you can just watch the episode as a
self-contained thing you'll get what's
going on and you'll decide if the vibe
is yours
so having now made that recommendation
i need to start talking about some of
the specifics that are a little bit more
spoilery which does
ultimately also include me talking about
my favorite character who i also think
he just exemplifies why i will always
keep coming back to the show
let's talk
about harvey
if you are
continuing on because you've decided you
didn't want to check out the show first
or you've just how you don't care about
spoilers for context
harvey
exists only in john's head
he's kind of scorpius but he's also not
he's what's called a neural clone he is
something that scorpius implanted in
john's head with the goal of extracting
information out of john that scorpius
was unable to attain through his normal
interrogation and torture techniques
so harvey
is a copy of
scorpius who's in john's head
but because he's in john's head he has
access to john's
cultural references
his sense of humor
and over time harvey becomes this
amalgamation
of scorpius and john
he is very much his own thing
he will drop pop culture references he
will manipulate scenes of him talking
with john inside john's head into being
police interrogations or the two of them
riding a roller coaster or them at a
construction site or harvey will be in a
pink bunny suit
harvey
is the embodiment of the fact
that for a good chunk of this show
crichton is literally losing his mind
and harvey is there to egg him along the
whole way
harvey is
the kind of character
that i can look to
and go
i can't get that anywhere else
a lot of the other characters or a lot
of the other aspects like i could get
something like that somewhere
dargo is very klingonesque as much as i
love him to death so like i could find a
dargo style character
zan is very chill and very zen plenty of
characters like that out there aaron is
the tough no-nonsense action woman those
are a dime a dozen a bunch of them
played by claudia black especially in
video games so like i can find
equivalents to most of these things
somewhere else
but not harvey
harvey is his own beast and harvey is
judiciously used he could have very
easily been overdone oversaturated and
just sucked the oxygen out of the room
if he was used too much but he is used
in the perfect amounts he's not there
all the time but when he's there it's
glorious and it makes you excited for
the next time he's gonna show up and
then there's just all this little stuff
a lot of it's just about the
interactions and the way these
characters relate to each other
dargo and john build the most beautiful
bro-style relationship after initially
really not getting along like to the
point that they actually kind of agree
like look we just need to accept that we
are never going to be friends and at the
time they say that you kind of believe
it
but you also then get to watch that grow
even rigel
who should be
just a big pain in the ass
and he is that
but he's endearing and lovable and very
well puppeted and the god the creatures
aliens it the weirdness of this show
permeates everything the concepts are
weird the characters are real weird
whether they be one-off aliens who
appear or core concepts like freaking
harvey
it's weird
and i love
something weird like
you know what
this is what i think i would pitch
for escape as
you know
the star wars cantina scene in a new
hope i was just packed to the gills with
weirdness strangeness
imagine a whole show where that vibe is
just the entire thing
there's no normal
this is the normal the weird is the
normal but it keeps shaking it up and
because we have john there to ground it
the normal never becomes too predictable
because we have our grounded human
element who is reacting to it the way
that we are
it's
such a fun show and it ends really well
after a frankly terrible
cliffhanger at the end of the fourth
season when it got cancelled and they
knew they were canceled when they did
that cliffhanger they had no business
pulling that
but
the mini-series that finishes it off
peacekeeper wars
ends it really well
for something that's it starts strong
too like the premiere episode is real
good premieres are never this good
it's a really good premiere
it has its bumps along the way
there's a couple of duds but even the
duds are usually
interesting are still oh
okay like that didn't quite work but
that was kind of cool idea or that was a
neat touch or that was a nifty alien
there's really nothing in this that is
devoid of something some entertainment
some value to take from it and most of
it is steeped in that
it is so good it is so fun it is
thrilling
awesome
and i just had to gush
have you watched it i hope you will
and have you heard my podcast
i hope you do that as well
but in any case what do you think about
farscape
whatever you think drop something down
the comments let's talk about it like
share and subscribe patreon is what
covers the bills enables me to do this
the podcast the whole deal i couldn't do
this without that help
but even if you can't do that
all the other stuff helps me out as well
interacting with the video sharing it
around that helps
but
don't worry too much about it
because
at the end of the day
are the council
i'm just running the meetings
and until next time
this council
is adjourned
just remember who your daddy is
tell him who his daddy is i'm your daddy
[Music]
it's the end credits means i gotta shout
out some patrons this month it is turok
oliver b linda walters tt robin powell
fronabilax the poodle idlen tracy
scrabbon dharma michael doyle vincent
paul bartolucci angry casper adam lefty
taylor robin moore shayla gourlay and
bookworm
thanks so much for your support
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]